opinions determine our experience of
life more than anything else our
opinions provide us with who we think we
are and how we see the world as a result
we hold our opinions very tightly for we
fear that if we lose them we will become
void of our identity we hate few things
more in life than having someone oppose
and strip us of an opinion when our
opinions are challenged and proven wrong
it often feels as though our identity
has been weakened and diminished but why
must this be the case it is not our
identity that is being challenged but
merely an extension of it our opinions
are like glasses through which we view
and discern the world around us but just
like how over time the prescription of
one's glasses may change so must our
opinions as our understanding of life
changes the prescription of our opinions
must change with it for another opinion
to disprove our own only serves to
benefit us because it gives us the
opportunity to replace our old lenses
for potentially new and improved ones
all the while our identity as the
individual who is wearing the glasses
can remained integral and constant and
so we must learn how to accept and
embrace this process as a positive thing
more important than having opinions in
life is having good ones progressive
ones sharp ones the only way to possess
opinions with such sharpness is through
the willingness to listen to and
consider other opinions with rationality
and objectivity and see if compared to
ours they provide a clearer and improved
image of the world we should embrace our
own opinions and fight to defend them
but only once we have removed our ego
from the equation and considered the
opposing opinions with legitimate
open-mindedness there is very little
that any person can be certain about in
this life and we must self admit that we
are all merely humans with a constantly
changing and loose grip of reality we
have opinions to help us navigate and
create meaning in life but we must not
let them in combination with our ego
sweep us away into believing that we are
able to construe an ultimate reality
just as others have the potential to
have mislead opinions so don't you as we
are introduced to new experiences ideas
and understandings in life our opinions
must change accordingly and if we are
willing to adapt our identity can move
fluidly with them our life will then
improve because we will become able to
rationalize and exchange opinions with
others in a cohesive and beneficially
effective way by slightly detaching your
ego and identity from your opinions you
can embrace the fact that you are not
always right and as a result you will
not always be wrong
thank you for watching if we found
enjoyment and value in this video please
give it a thumbs up share your thoughts
in the comments below and if you are not
already be sure to subscribe to our
Channel
we are constantly coming out with new
videos to help you experience life with
clarity and Wonder